na vida e na vida que se leva é o
aprendizado e o que se desse a semente
posse do legado
ou seja não adianta aprender e não
querem repassar o conhecimento
coleguinha lá então a gente tem que
aprender e passar na vida que se leva o
aprendizado e o que de si a semente
fosse do legado será alguém pra muitos
né pra pouco dizer a verdade fruto da
minha coxa e já colhi me traz felicidade
na cidade às margens da sociedade só
sombra da estrela que brilhou no
possibilidade mas pra quem que tem razão
o dia também foi na selva todo dia um
leão e ainda dizer amém
não sei onde estava vergonha na cara do
contratantes que escolheu o cabelo livro
rejeitou os meus tuba anses foi
intitulada mão de obra barata
não investiguei graças ensinamento de
afrika bambaataa sem rodas do vento
bússola a 100 mil nós i antessala idade
me guiou para trilhas do fossi navio
negreiro gemidos tormentos eu ouço e que
se for o com o tempo a se bata só foi
trocada por uma prancheta e esse bilhões
a caneta não arrebenta mas não cair e
carne fraca nem pensar
me levantei do anonimato pra poder
reivindicam
contrariei as estatísticas de fato
mulher de jogo no final dilma aqui não
cai do salto
tô no palco sou professora graças ao
alto que sempre foi meu alicerce
carregando o fardo de bronze na aluísia
marin a guerra não para mais uma
guerreira na trincheira preta hora
saudações africana grassi ganso
[Aplausos]